CBS News Royal contributor Tina Brown
joins us now she has chronicled the
British Monarchy for decades good
morning Tina always good to have you on
these occasions now we just heard
Camilla's friends say that you know she
it was tough for her they went through
her trash but it was so much worse than
that can you just briefly tell us how
bad was it for her for Camilla and how
is she able to turn it around it was so
bad for her that she really spent like
about a year in hiding after the
famously embarrassing tape got leaked of
her and Charles talking about intimate
stuff about their love life well he said
he wanted to be her tampon that was kind
of and he wanted to live inside her
pajamas so it was absolutely crushing
and she literally had to hide because
the Press was so vile they called her on
oh bag an old trout uh uh you know a
vampire somebody called her once and you
know she was so used to it she used to
sign her love letters to Charles you're
devoted all back because she was so used
to being trashed so you know this went
on and on and then of course just when
he was about to bring her out into the
the guy after he was divorced from Diana
dies yeah and so once again she almost
has to go back into hiding again for
another year or two because
obviously Diana was so adored suddenly
once again she was cast as you know the
hated usurper who's caused Diana great
unhappiness but now she's she's going to
be Queen has she been accepted by the
public in Britain do you think she has
because you know she she is in fact a
very warm very earthy very human kind of
woman and she simply gone on and got on
with it and done her royal duties with
Charles since she's been married really
flawlessly I mean they've been married
in 18 years now and you know it's a long
time and she's actually in that time
proved that she's a credibly uh you know
good working Royal essentially and the
queen was incredibly impressed with that
because the queen felt it was all about
are you about public service and and
Camilla won her round after not being a
fan of hers for a long time
what's the significance for King Charles
this weekend
oh my gosh when you saw him in opening
parliament in for the queen before she
died and he was look there's a crown
sitting next to him and you look at it
he's looking at going like when when you
know so yes he has wanted this all his
life obviously it is the apotheosis of
his life it's it's the it's the big
moment now Prince Harry will be at the
coronation without Meghan Markle um how
do you expect that to go given the
tensions within the family I think it's
going to go fine I mean Harry knows how
to behave I mean he's you know he
understands that this is a very big
moment for his father uh but everybody's
going to be watching everyone is getting
how is he treated exactly well they
wanted obviously what they have all been
afraid of is the attention going to to
Harry which is why Megan's decision not
to go was probably the best decision
because in a way it kept that separate
you know it wasn't going to be a circus
of Paparazzi which is not distracting it
would not be so distracting but that has
been the great desire this word fine I
mean that's not good and you were my
former editor and used to call some of
my writing fine and it wasn't good
there's no good I mean no touchy female
reunions that's for sure this is not
going to be the occasion for big hugs
afterwards absolutely not you know this
is I don't think that a there won't be
any time for it but also relations
between Charles uh William and Harry are
very very icy I'm told they're at the
lowest point ever actually no
relationship there so it won't happen
Prince William has a major role in the
coronation yes he does he is uh this is
the moment when he will he will be the
only one who kneels uh to Charles and
and kiss gives literally sort of an
allegiance kisses him on the on the
right cheek uh on the right cheek yes on
the right cheek it is going to be I
would imagine a very sort of emotional
time for William too because you know
he's looking at this and thinking me
next and how long you know and indeed
little George Little Prince George I
don't know how much he really
understands because George will succeed
Williams George will succeed William and
this is going to be his Destiny unless
he decides I'm out of here
President Biden won't be there as a
matter of tradition but uh first lady
Jill Biden will be there yes Joe Biden
will be coming I think with her
granddaughter she's bringing her uh
there's going to be a hundred Crown uh
heads uh coming 100 heads of state
becoming it's going to be in massive
security challenge I think for uh
Scotland Yard they have 11 000 police
out that day in a pricey Affair too yeah
it's a security is the biggest expense
it's a big day you say it's going to be
a very glorious day
it is going to be a glorious day because
nobody does pageantry traditional Brits
you are so right that trumpets will
sound spot on there I love the Pomp and
Circumstances of how you all do it thank
you Tina thank you guys and I know
you'll be here Saturday morning I will
certainly be there bright and early
thank you CBS News we'll have live
coverage of the coronation from
Westminster Abbey on Saturday that
starts at five o'clock Eastern time